So what were you like as a kid?
I remember when I was just a few years older than you,...
...your great grandpa Abe and your great grandma Rose and her sisters...
...came over to our apartment for Thanksgiving.
After dinner, I found this tape recorder lying around...
...and somehow I got the idea to interview them.
A few years later, your great grandpa and your great grandma...
...and all her sisters passed away...
...but I remembered I'd made that tape.
So I went looking for it but I couldn't find it.
I don't get it, why do you keep looking for it?
You know, doing that recording really taught me something.
You can find the most amazing stories from regular people.
All you have to do is ask them about their lives and listen.
We can learn so much about the people all around us,...
...even about the people you already know...
...just by taking the time to have a conversation.
And if you pay just a little attention, you'll find wisdom and poetry in their words.
Most people love to be listened to because it tells them how much their lives matter.
When you're curious, treat people with respect...
...and have just a little courage to ask the important questions.
Great things are gonna happen.